...prilude, imamo pravna pravila,
to su ona pravila
koja ima uleđenu funkcionisane države
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisane države,
koja su podlano čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti,
tu imamo državne dane
na različitom stepenu vlasti.
A kod koordinacije imamo isti
stepen vlasti i imamo saradnje.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se ja da zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Kada je reč o ljudima,
krenut ćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade, kako rade i kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciji.
Državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svo straništvo,
taj državni aparat čine samo neke
ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim spužbenim licima.
To su ljudi
koji rade u imenu za račun država.
E sad, tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određene
poslove. Uvod u posao je jednostavno,
ne da se držim definicije dužbenika,
nego najprostije je da ga objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao, daže ga jednom
državnom tvrdnom oblicu i kažeš evo ti,
napravo radi to, to je tvoja nadležnost.
Bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ću vam nju objasniti, i prisutna je
naravno u radu državnih vodana,
Ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno lice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službeno lice, da li oni rade isti?